as you're walking the corner of our eye
we saw a bit of a ditch at the bottom
here at the grave so I'd say there's a
water bottle there we pulled the water
bottle around look at how easy we found
some of the magic
slam net is racing funds to establish a
Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a Santa khajari for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you and a shot of American award click
the link and donate what you can
assalamu alaikum brothers and sisters
and dear friends I came across a video
on Instagram where a group of brothers
are walking past the grave and they see
that something or someone it might be a
cat or whatever has stuck up a little
hole a little there's a little ditch
underneath a grief they get close and
this is what they found let's watch for
ourselves very very strange and bizarre
just come to handle Cemetery me Sage
Jack and myself we're walking up here
this is the grave of habibles around
Khalifa don't know who they are but as
we're walking with corner of our eye we
saw a bit of a ditch at the bottom here
at the grave so I'd say there's a water
bottle there we pulled the water bottle
around because it's our reasons we found
some of the magic but they don't Magic
on someone who's close it seems like
he's been dug for a while this holder
it's not new put it back in the bottle
bring the bottle
so guys as you can see the brothers
subhanallah they go to this person's
grave may Allah have mercy on him and
they see that literally
um folded paper that's overfolded papers
subhanallah God knows if it's connected
to this person's grave or somebody
specifically asked brothers and sisters
well like this shows us how dangerous
the times we live in this and not only
that we see physical threats only as a
threat somebody who's coming with a
knife towards me two people walking
towards me looking dangerous and we take
precautions we don't walk at the
argument's sake you know some people do
not walk at night some certain people
drive somewhere certain people have a
friend they have we have all these
devices so we'll keep in check you know
if you send it through Uber a friend by
an Uber track where they're going Etc we
have all these precautions and
measurements to keep people safe for the
armor weapons Etc brothers and sisters
there is a metaphysical reality the
prophet salallahu in the narration put
into the grace and he said do you know
how many people are in this graves
because of iron because of evil eye
this is a reality there are evil people
out there now what Allah in his
messenger given us your Edgar I advise
you I'm telling you guys I'm a public
figure yeah I get a lot of Envy jealousy
not that I'm anything special but I get
it I don't know why people are so
jealous about it I'll be honest with you
there's nothing to be jealous about
subhanallah but anyways the point is
what you get it how could you not do
your cat it's as if you're waking up and
going to a battlefield the people are
shooting each other they're walking
right in the middle and you get hit and
I go ah why did I get hit brothers and
sisters this is a reality Allah says
when they send Sarah as a test with the
angels told the people not to disbelief
and you know what's interesting they
don't use the sale for murder they don't
use the sale for
um any whatever it may be power they use
it to break the family units they use it
to attack the family unit the divorce
unbelievable that shows you how powerful
marriage marriage unit is and that's the
reason why I've started the bitter truth
Show the marriage documentary show is
coming out soon and I'm working on an
app which is not a matrimony service I'm
working on that because this is a direct
attack the biggest threat that we have
today subhanallah please protect
yourself do you as God is it a character
I'm going to recommend you guys please
download that every morning and evening
you have to do your card you have to one
lie I never used to I got hit so bad
brothers and sisters I do not miss my
car from that moment onwards there is a
metaphysical reality and shiatina Jinn
they are going to these levels of put
engraving people's going to levels of
doing certain people's Graves protect
yourself Allah has given protection use
it if you don't don't cry about it
that's all I'm going to say do not cry
about it once you get hit don't cry
about it every believer Salah is your
defense like we did a video about that
woman who did Magic Singer she said I
can't touch these Muslims believers they
have like a dome protecting them when
faced with various religions it is very
difficult to influence Muslims they are
in a constant connection with the
aggregor Allah is protecting you do your
Salah do you can't do everything Allah
says ordered you to do and do you
yes and this amounts to cover those who
involved in Magic said and the capital
punishment is done for this that's how
severe it is may Allah protect you guys
inshallah this Ramadan Mormon sisters
take a look after yourself and please
inshallah guys do not forget to support
our campaign inshallah as we are
teaching Rivers how to praise Salah
inshallah step by step through our
website one-to-one sessions give them a
prayer mat and many other things that we
do with Productions where we encourage
people to praise Salah and teach them
how to pray Salah please support that
assalamu alaikum
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a southern for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you and reward click the link and donate
what you can